you have this crazy thing you go you
become crazy successful right and you
get some confidence from the military I
imagine yeah when do you go like and why
Finance you go from the military to
finance why man I love numbers how
simple is that I mean I can't tell you
how much I love numbers oh yeah I love
anything to do everything here's numbers
number of cameras angles how you're
seated you know the books you know the
the buy books by foot you know 10 feet
20 feet here everything is how much you
love numbers you took the SAT and then
walked out of the verbal portion which
means you literally just wanted a story
listen I'm not getting any comments I
just want to do this test and I I love
listen when I was in the Army I bought a
math analysis book just to do math
analysis in the Army in my Barracks
that's how we this is not a story I
proudly share but that's how much I love
numbers so when I when I worked at
Morgan Stanley Deanwood and I'm looking
at the series seven everything like you
realize you're gonna fail this test you
know if you fail it you're not going to
get a job here I'm like let me give it a
shot and then you take this 37 first
time if you fail you lost your you you
get fired boom I'm like I love this
world look at this what if he can do
this and you can take money and do this
with any but this is what about this
investment how about the it's a
beautiful game I mean to me capitalism
is all a game if you if you look at this
game of like the whole concept of
business you're playing the game and
you're killing it right I mean flagrant
you guys are killing it your podcast
your show as a comedian the whole
concept of a comedian how you do it you
know if you're too disconnected from the
audience you're not going on the road to
kind of see the reaction how they
reacted how many of the people reacting
to this Joke Man women most of them were
men none of them were women what if I
can do this how about if I come that's
all numbers everything with your world
is also mathematical formula behind it
so for me
when I got into the financial services I
was like oh I found my home and I said
I'm gonna go 20 years yeah I said I'm
gonna go 20 years in and I won 20 years
October of 09 uh after Morgan Stanley
Deanwood I go to Transamerica and
they're seven and a half years yeah then
I see what's going on the marketplace
and I'm seeing the fact that you know
the insurance industry is filled with 56
year old white male yeah and I saw no
one else is going from women selling
Insurance do you know anything about
insurance at this time nothing my
parents have did you have insurance my
parents haven't I've never lived in a
house my parents owned they've never
owned Insurance they've never we didn't
even have auto insurance back in the
basement
he was a cashier at a 99 cent store no
we got nothing
zero okay and I kept asking my mom you
guys sure we don't have some kind of a
relative that's got oil I'm looking for
one Uncle does anybody have money
nothing
zero so you're like all right it
I'll just dominate the insurance
business yeah
now how did you dominate you said there
was a basically a white space where
everybody is yeah so that you can let me
tell you there was a couple things that
was going this applies to every business
this applies to whatever you do in your
life so these guys wrote this book
called Blue Ocean strategy if you've
never read it you got to read it okay so
in the core concept of Blue Ocean
strategy is how can you be everybody's
making fun of these guys How about if
I'm not going to compete for this space
I'm gonna go do comedy here everybody's
playing this game I'm gonna everybody's
selling to these guys I'm gonna go sell
here so I'm looking at insurance and I
said okay everybody's targeting this
audience no one's targeting the fastest
growing audience in America as the
Hispanic audience and no one is
recruiting women only 17 percent of
agents are women you're kidding me no
perfect that's what we're going to be
doing boom we uh Target that audience
the financial industry was going away
from social media because they were
scared everything was every
communication you have with your client
you have to document it we can't do that
social media is not waiting for you so I
dropped my Securities license I focused
only on life fast forward to today we
just sold the company a year ago we have
roughly 45 000 people we've licensed in
49 different states 54 or so are women
51 percent are Hispanic in a company and
the average age is 34 years old you come
to a convention you're going to look at
the audience you're going to say there's
no way in the world this is an insurance
conference a big ass party how much how
much did you sell the company for a few
hundred million dollars a few hundred
million is a wonderful way okay so you
get complete Financial Freedom you don't
have to work another day in your life I
don't have to work a single day in my
life and then you decide to be a
YouTuber
yeah
you know the youtubing thing kind of
started 2013. right well I'm like yeah
let me do a video a week called two
minutes with Pat we do 100 videos only
the last video was two minutes
everything else was seven minutes nine
minutes 12 minutes and then uh we kind
of grown like listen there's an audience
for entrepreneurship let's pick one word
we've been entrepreneur created a bunch
of business content and I said I'm not
touching politics every time I did
politics Mario would say Pat you're
talking Paul this is not politics but
you said you don't want to do political
content okay we can't do this one let's
change it and then eventually I take a
break right up like 450 000 subs and I
said I'm not doing this right now we
took a three-month break I was having
kids and families busy I'm traveling six
months on the road so I said if we come
back we got to really compete we got to
really do something with this and then
we bought the domain valuetainment yeah
from a publicly traded company and we
picked it up they changed their
company's name to Value tease then we
started changing the structure we're
gonna do some interviews we're going to
talk to some people like yourself and
boom that became interesting we do an
interview with Michael Francis under
cover world star everybody's messaging
us and we're like wait a minute this
thing just got that many views to send
out this many views yeah what can we do
now my good friend Chase is a uh
Long Island or something like that where
was he around here he was he was making
uh you know uh uh anywhere between two
to ten million a week and a gas business
yeah he was a smart mobster he was a
smart mob rare yes yeah yeah he found a
hat yes what was it what was the gas
hack again the gas tax the 41 cents this
is this is brilliant yeah because he
wasn't paying the gas tax yeah yeah and
he connected with the actual gas
stations right yes yeah yeah him and the
Russian mob work together closely and he
could get gas cheaper than anybody else
for you 20 cent discount for you and
everybody was calling him he was the guy
that was running everybody and then next
thing you know they're like wait a
minute this guy's making the The Fortune
Magazine comes at the top 50 most
powerful Mobsters in America he's on
like number 13 list at the age of 30
okay Sammy was a under boss under Gotti
but and Sammy made money but Michael was
known as the earner yeah yeah yeah okay
so you get into these mob guys and
you're doing a bunch of these interviews
and when do you pivot when does it
become when do you feel like you can
affect culture a little bit more because
I feel like now that you're tapping more
into culture I don't like to call it
politics I think politics is a
reflection of culture but I feel like
you're talking a lot more about culture
and the things that you're saying it's
not only motivational stuff when it
comes to business but it's also opinion
when it comes to you know societal
breakdown if you will so so you know in
in Hollywood they they look at actors
like Justin Timberlake and they call
them what you know they call them triple
threat right this guy can dance he can
sing he can act right there's not a lot
of them out there that are good in those
three areas right if you were to look at
some of the names maybe you put Will
Smith in there maybe you put Chris Brown
in there but then you have Justin
Timberlake yeah that's terrible Jamie
Foxx 100 Jamie foxxy 100 Jamie Foxx
um
so for me I'm looking at the game and
I'm studying everybody and I said okay
this guy is a great host
that is a skill set what's a great host
what do you think what do you think do
you agree with each other what do you
disagree with what he has to say how
about yourself well so that's a whole
that's a skill set right to be a great
host Like Larry King is a great host
but nobody will say what was Larry
King's opinion on XYZ that's not his
game he played this Ronnie Johnson on
Inside the NBA you say that again
Johnson on Inside the NBA
absolutely he is a great host right but
if I ask you right now what is Ernie's
opinion on XYZ you're not going to think
about it right then you have talent
opinion Barclay yeah that guy makes the
show right yeah Talent opinion you know
here's what I think we are they're
making a mistake these guys are a bunch
of idiots you know San Antonio
underwears are the biggest you know let
me tell you yeah what is this guy
talking about yeah but he's entertaining
yeah Chuck you can't say that why'd you
just say this I got to say this the
truth okay so you got a host you got
the the talent uh the opinion and then
you got analyst yeah Kenny Smith which
means let me give you an idea why based
on this data okay each is attracted by a
different kind of an audience right if
you can do all three now you got a
different kind of a element of talent so
for for me I looked at this and I said
okay I enjoy this okay I enjoy listening
to Banter conversation but then I got
opinions about different things so there
is risk with the opinion game big time
that's the risk so a lot of times I have
again I had a meeting with this guy
today billionaire business guy Hollywood
Music you know what we talked about for
breakfast you can't talk in his world
and give what he really thinks about his
opinion if he does it could ruin a lot
of his business and his life yeah so
there's a risk into doing that one
eventually I said you know what I'm
gonna do this with valuetainment here's
my opinion here's what I believe here's
what I do if you don't like it I totally
get it but I'm gonna give it to you from
my POV and then I'm going to do pbd
podcast and I want to talk about
everything and I got a lot of interest
in culture family parenting kids economy
politics add them all together so there
was an evolution in it first I was just
creating content to talk business then I
started interviewing then it's
opinion and then you know that's kind of
it came about do you think you'd be able
to do it if you were still running the
insurance business not the way I'm doing
it today because they'd attack you for
it oh my you're they're doing it today
but I say okay great what do you want me
to do really uh I haven't seen a lot of
people go at you yet no no when I'm from
the space Oh it will happen in this
space yeah in the space in the insurance
industry so when I'm out of course
they're competing with it they opened
the company and I'm in the process of
wanting to sell the company if the
company has a category where my opinions
are linked to XYZ a buyer doesn't want
to buy the company because did you hear
what the founder said did you hear what
this guy so there's an element of that
where you have to massage your way
through on what you really want to say I
think it's wise to do it anyways uh but
today the handcuffs are the handcuffs
are off today was that also part of the
draw of starting your own YouTube
channels I sold my business and not
starting but really getting to now I can
finally say what I feel whereas before
you had to conceal it first yeah yes
yeah there's a Liberation to have in the
you money yeah
exactly especially if you're gonna if
you're gonna have very strong opinions
and you have very strong opinions
[Music]